me pidieron que calculará la
probabilidad de ganar el premio mayor de
la lotería de mega millions esta es una
de las dos loterías más importantes de
eeuu para poder saber qué quiere decir
esto de ganar el premio mayor déjenme
explicarles en qué consiste esta lotería
tenemos dos urnas una tiene 56 pelotas
la dibujo por aquí 56 y la otra que voy
a dibujar en naranja aquí a la derecha
tiene 46 pelotas la pinto por aquí
entonces lo que se hace es que tenemos
que sacar 5 pelotas de la una de 56 y
tenemos que asignarle a todas ellas
podemos atinar leds en cualquier orden
pero si tienen que hacer esas voy a
dibujar las pelotas por aquí una pelota
dos pelotas tres pelotas cuatro pelotas
una más cinco pelotas y como ya les
conté para que estas pelotas las
tengamos bien debemos atinarle a los
números que aparecen con el chance de
que podemos adivinar las en cualquier
orden y tenemos que obtener la pelota
naranja también bien entonces de estas
46 se saca una pelota que tiene 46
posibilidades ya está también tenemos
que atinar
pues ésta se elige de 46 entonces para
encontrar la probabilidad de ganar
tenemos que calcular 1 entre todas las
posibles combinaciones que tenemos
entonces esencialmente lo que tenemos
que hacer es encontrar las combinaciones
de pelotas blancas y multiplicar la por
46 que son las posibilidades de pelotas
naranjas y para las pelotas blancas
podemos pensar en términos combinatorios
con algunas fórmulas matemáticas
en concreto podemos pensar que hay un
conjunto de 56 estamos eligiendo 5
pelotas es decir que estamos obteniendo
56 en 5 pero para hacer un poco más
concretos también podemos hacerlo con
los números exactos entonces la primera
pelotita tiene 56 posibilidades entonces
como no estamos reemplazando la pelota
la siguiente
tiene 55 posibilidades la siguiente
tiene 54 posibilidades la que va después
tiene 53 posibilidades y la última y la
última tiene 52 posibilidades porque ya
elegimos cuatro pelotas ahora este
número de aquí sería el número correcto
si tuviéramos que asignarle también al
orden
pero como ya dijimos que no nos importa
tenemos que dividir todavía entre otro
número porque podemos adivinar en
cualquier orden entonces para que
nuestras cuentas vayan bien lo que
tenemos que hacer es dividir entre la
cantidad de formas en las cuales podemos
ordenar cinco objetos pues vamos a
dividir entre y vamos a pensarlo a ver
si estamos ordenando cinco cosas la
primera tiene cinco posibilidades la
siguiente tiene cuatro posibilidades la
siguiente tiene tres la siguiente dos y
la última como ya pusimos todas las
cosas tiene solamente una posibilidad
entonces este número de aquí nos da la
cantidad de formas de obtener nuestras
cinco pelotitas y así ya no nos importa
el orden voy a sacar la calculadora para
hacer la cuenta nos da 55 no perdón 56 x
55 x 54 x 53 x 52 y eso tenemos que
dividirlo entre 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 ya
para que por 1 pero lo ponemos por 1
entonces esto de aquí nos da
aproximadamente como 3.8 millones
bueno este número de aquí lo vamos a
pasar para acá que es un número de
verdad entonces vamos a copiarlo de este
lado 3 millones 819 mil 816 y esa es la
cantidad de posibilidades de obtener las
pelotas blancas bien es uno entre 3.8
millones más o menos eso ya es bajo y
aunque esto de aquí vaya bien todavía
tenemos que atinar le alabó la naranja a
una de 46 entonces multiplicamos estas
posibilidades por 46 traemos la
calculadora porque son cuentas muy
grandes y eso nuestra respuesta anterior
la multiplicamos por 46 y vamos a ver
que obtenemos obtenemos pues un poquito
menos que 176 millones un poquito menos
que 176 millones voy a dejar la
calculadora aquí al lado y vamos a
copiar el número por acá lo voy a poner
a la derecha con color blanco
175 millones 711 mil 536 posibilidades
en las cuales pueden aparecer los
números entonces la probabilidad de
ganar es 1 entre este número total
1 entre aproximadamente 176 millones
para poner esta pequeña probabilidad en
contexto busque internet cuál es la
probabilidad de que te caiga un rayo en
toda tu vida resulta que esta
probabilidad es aproximadamente de 1
entre 10.000 ahora si nos preguntamos no
porque te caiga un rayo sino dos podemos
hacernos una mejor idea para pensar un
poco más fácilmente pensemos en la
probabilidad de que a ti ya tu mejor
amigo les caiga un rayo en toda su vida
de manera independiente es decir cada
quien por su lado para esto hay que
multiplicar otra vez por uno entre
10.000 y eso nos da 1 entre 1 seguido de
8 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ceros aquí voy a
hacer una aproximación un poco inexacta
pero servirá para darnos una idea estos
cálculos nos dicen que aproximadamente
tienes el doble de probabilidad de que
un rayo te caiga dos veces en tu vida
que ganarte el premio mayor de mega
millions guau